daily wire inside jokes is there any one
of them that i should know about oh yeah
there's this really hilarious
joke that ben wants to fire me it's a
joke
it's not real please i have a kid now
[Music]
i am new to nashville so what is it or
do on weekends listen to your screaming
child
if you were famous for something else
what would you be famous for
my spaghetti a la carbonaro
a good proper spaghetti a la carbonara
is
the pasta the pancetta the guanciale or
the bacon or whatever
egg cheese pepper that's it yeah done
but no cream
no peas some people do this it's
ridiculous if you could add anyone to
mount rushmore who would it be
and why i would add william bradford
i would add the governor of plymouth
plantation he i think the kind of
plymouth story
refounding the kind of religious basis
of america
that's what i would do he's a dead white
man yeah exactly what was the worst job
you ever had
worst job i ever had i was a
professional actor for a few years that
was pretty cool
actors suck not you but like it sounds
so terrible to say that i
i've always liked my jobs i can say the
best job i've ever had was nannying one
of my best jobs i ever had
i was a subway sandwich artist you see
and it's so you love kids so you like
i love hoagies if you could have someone
like a personal assistant follow you
around all the time what would you have
them do
all the time uh i would probably have
them go away i don't like it i don't
want people in my business
i mean maybe if they're gonna follow me
all day take pictures of the back of my
head if you ever wonder we look like
from behind like you never see
yourself from behind do i drops off
essentially yeah what was your favorite
toy and or
hobby growing up i sound like like i was
such a just boring child
because i can't i think yeah i know my
favorite toy was like my cigar
this kind of a category of choice was my
cap guns i think they're probably like
illegal now i did love those i know as a
psycho
my toy ar-15s i think i actually did
have a toyota or 15. what about you
favorite toy gosh i mean i used to love
board games and i definitely did like
barbies
yeah yeah it's like a thing i don't know
i know that seems like very gender
typical
i had action figures had a lot of action
yeah and i saw a ken
doll but in my to my mind it was just an
action like a big action figure
so i asked i was like hey mom can i get
the kendall she was like
no if you could live anywhere in the
world for a year
where would it be japan easy never been
i loved i don't it's a weird thing since
i was a kid i've been obsessed with
japan
i guess you know for me it's pretty
simple i i would live in italy probably
i love italy i've spent a good amount of
time in italy with a nice fat cigar and
a little more
yeah tomatoes in the backyard yes so it
certainly it would be italy
second place though iceland you know
they have the highest rate of alcoholism
in the world do they if there's
something at darkness and it's just cool
the national food is hakar which is
urine soaked shark
and the national drink is brenevan which
is also known as black death
you are on death row for a bad tweet
from 10 years ago
so what's your final meal i want sweet
little elise's
homemade lasagna if i had that lasagna
as my last meal i wouldn't need to
execute it the next day i would die and
go to heaven
[Laughter]
i make the best lasagna is that so it
takes me
four hours to make the sauce really oh
halfway right
that is like if you say to my husband
like what's kansas meal it's like
lasagna is this
what would harassment final meal be i
wouldn't want to be a burn to the
taxpayer yeah
because i'm going to go out as a
conservative yeah so i'm going to just
have a quarter pounder meal with cheese
and a large fry i might even be crazy
and get an extra large fry wow okay
why not calories don't count the zombie
apocalypse is coming
who are the three people that you want
on your team you gotta take two people
that you can survive with
definitely taking donald trump jr i'm
picking people that are known obviously
and my husband because they're
outdoorsmen so like they can shoot you
just want outdoors
people third person is someone that you
want to throw the zombie so i would take
hillary clinton
oh yeah you know you need to get a head
start yeah they're going to find those
zombies they're going to suicide
hanging in their settings
they all killed them they were depressed
they were depressed zombies
i am cousins with hillary clinton oh i
am it's like cousins
in law like it's through marriage but i
actually am like not that distantly uh
related to hillary i just want to be
clear it's not going to save you it's
not i know
yes who would i take i want one person
to shoot for me so there i'm i'm
thinking of like i don't know
some killer like dana white or someone
really it's tough
yeah i want someone to eat
you know if it really comes down to it i
want someone to really you know
have some good repartee with some sort
of like a poet
courtney b carter maybe cardi b you know
because it might it would be fun
it would be what is something you would
have liked to know at the beginning of
your career
i wish i would have known that 90
of what politicians say is bs
these five bullet points that the gop is
spatting out this is eternally true
but like no it's not yeah i think you
should read plato's apology
yes yes they had that right early you
know what i mean they do yes
what fictional character do you wish
that you could meet
i said that i would like to meet an
x-men and it would be mystique
and matt didn't know who mystique was i
don't so i've showed him
what what is going on in this place
you've never seen x-men no i've heard of
batman i don't is that
okay you didn't read x-men comics
growing up no me neither no
oh yeah no no yeah no totally uh but i
saw the movies guys this is so exciting
okay you need to sit down and watch
every x movie but mystique
she does this oh she does that oh
wow that's impressive is that a
superpower yeah i know okay well all
right
what song do you have completely
memorized sound of music i know that
stuff backward and forward i love the
sound of music it was like
legit my favorite movie growing up like
i was in my room as a little girl
really well because i didn't know really
what the movie was about yeah
i hate these guys loves edelweiss
yeah and like it's just like we need to
bring i have i have to tell you when you
said we were just talking about the
nazis and everything and when you said
my son loves adol i i was nervous about
how it was going to end but
edelweiss beautiful song sentence
yes yes what is one of your songs that
you know oh man i've memorized
so i hope it's like some really like
dirty hip hop what would someone know
somebody wouldn't like expect you to
know like do you know any
rap songs oh yeah anyone like
like hip hop hippie i do i actually do
know that song
yeah i also i know like uh you know
biggie smalls
oh yeah you know the one about like uh
super nintendo and they call me big papa
what about um
da da da da da it's the mother f and d o
double g
yeah i can get into that one does
pineapple belong on pizza
absolutely not it's it's such a strong
no it's not even a question yeah it's
not any question it's actually it's
it's insane i don't have a problem the
idea of the pineapple pizza is you get
the salty and the sweet right so you get
the
salty ham and you get the sweet
pineapple but if you want that effect
you should get the far better pizza
which is honey sausage and onion honey
sounds like some real southern italian
kind of thing i don't know
uh yeah that's a good idea these
actually we give them pizza
and they still won't let us come in i
know i don't particularly believe that
is a hot dog a sandwich
the answer is no oh candace no come on
we agree on so much i feel like i'm not
gonna fit in here yeah you're not
what because there's a lot of misogyny
because you said it was a sandwich yeah
and matt walsh said it was a sandwich
and that is misogyny andrew cuomo said
it was a sandwich
why is it not a sandwich i just this is
this is this is the
the question itself isn't it fair enough
yeah it's not a sandwich
because the bread is not actually a part
okay i understand what i'm saying
i understand your objection yes however
is a hoagie a sandwich
a hoagie a whole i'm sorry i'm speaking
sort of oh subway like
a subway like a wave this is actually a
good city this
this is i've spent a lot of time on this
question you have
i will say you brought up a good i like
what you did there
yeah persuasion oh that's yeah that's in
my questions
that's the end yep oh that's the end of
mine too that's it did we win